so dc as a militarized zone new
allegations against the cuomo
administration two very controversial
bills headed to the senate let's see how
much we can get to
with tennessee republican senator
marshall blackburn welcome back senator
always good to have you
yes absolutely thank you it is a busy
day
it is i want to kick off a little bit
more the wall street journal broke this
news a couple of hours ago about
their allegations that top advisors
pressured changes to the reporting on
what was actually happening
in regard to nursing home people who
ended up dying from coven now new york
times has got a new report out as well
and they say that the governor's most
senior most aides wanted to hide
information they rewrote the report to
take it out that's according to
interviews and documents that the new
york times has seen they say the
extraordinary intervention came just as
mr cuomo was starting to write a book on
his covid
achievements and his pandemic
achievements it's the earliest act yet
known in what critics are calling a
months-long effort by the governor and
his aides to obscure the full scope
of what really happened with those
nursing home deaths your reaction
tonight
what we are seeing is that they chose to
manipulate
this information to serve their purposes
or to serve the governor's purposes
and shannon how heartbreaking this must
be
and certainly is to people that lost
their loved ones
because of the way this nursing home
scandal
was handled by putting these individuals
into these nursing homes when they knew
they had coveted
not using the other facilities that had
been made
available there in new york and now you
have this loss of life
you have a cover-up that seems to be
developing
and you have intentionality by the
governor
and his advisors to manipulate
this data and to hide the facts
his advisors again saying tonight bottom
line of the report that
didn't change is they say that march
25th directive that was sending people
back
coveted patients back to nursing homes
or banning testing of people for covid
going into nursing homes they say
that wasn't the driver of all of those
deaths that's their position
but as you said reaction tonight coming
from across the board we have a
democratic lawmaker in new york who's
tweeting out this is criminal i mean
there are going to be more questions
before we get some more answers on that
so i want to turn to some other things
that we want to talk to you about
tonight
which include the the barbed wire the
fences the national guardsmen and women
away from home for months here guarding
uh dc
um so this exclusive look we got at this
uh
report that's saying among other things
we could have a quick reaction force
that permanently resides within the dc
guard by reestablishing a military
police battalion staffing it with active
guard reserve troops who live in or near
the city year-round
perpetually on active duty could go up
to 130 million dollars
what have you been told about threats
that justify this level of security
we have not been told anything about
threats that justify this level of
security and i find it so interesting
shannon they don't think the border
works
wall works at the border but they do
think it works here in d.c and they want
to make it permanent
it needs to come down the fencing needs
to come down the capital
is the people's house to watch
democracy in action and we
know that january 6 was an intel
failure so it sends a bad
message to our foreign adversaries
we need to spend the money hiring
training and equipping
capital police but we do not need to
keep
this militarized zone up
in the middle of washington d.c the
guard troops
deserve to be home with their families
and not
on duty here in washington
and that that document that we got
thanks to jennifer griffin and lucas
tomlinson
is a draft we understand these are
proposals i want to move on to coveted
relief here's what your democratic
colleague senator chris
murphy had to say today about you guys
voting against helping the american
people that's the way he put it
republicans didn't have a problem
spending 1.9 trillion dollars to give
tax breaks to their wealthy friends i
don't know why they all of a sudden have
a problem
putting money into the pockets of
hard-working americans who are suffering
through the worst
health care crisis this country has seen
in
a century so how much of this nearly two
trillion dollar bill would actually help
real americans who desperately need it
and why are you voting no if you are
i will be a no vote on this and the
reason
you're seeing so many people it'll
probably be a party-line vote shannon
because only nine percent
of this two trillion dollar bill
actually goes to covet related
items you have one percent of this bill
that is being spent
on vaccines and there's already
one trillion dollars in the pipeline
that hasn't been
spent the appropriate thing is to
repurpose that money to get
timely targeted temporary relief
to individuals who desperately need it
because
of loss of their livelihoods making
certain that people are getting their
vaccinations
and when you talk about getting children
back in school
and people back to work my goodness we
have 67 billion dollars that has been
spent
on getting children back to school only
six billion dollars of that has been
pulled
down by school systems in the states
there is money in the system let's get
money to those that need the help
but another two trillion dollars that
would be a total of 5.5
trillion dollars what we do know is this
when you have a bill that only nine nine
percent
nine percent is there for covet relief
the rest is going to arts humanities
transportation bailouts for the big blue
states
and then also loan forgiveness for
different programs that the democrats
have decided they want to
practice loan forgiveness but see this
is a way that they are going to prepay
the advancement of their socialist
agenda
this is what they're going to use to say
thank you
to some of their big donors and people
that help them get elected earmarks are
coming back in this thing
and fortunately pelosi's subway
that earmark was pulled out because
people were so
up in arms these things have nothing to
do
with targeted relief for americans who
were suffering because of covet yeah
and i think everybody agrees that needs
to happen a lot of folks are in need
right now
we could show folks live on the senate
floor they're reading the entire bill
senator ron johnson republican insisted
on that says you all need to find out
what's in it
everybody else needs to hear what's in
it there will be an all-nighter for you
guys and then
hours of debate and it goes from there
senator blackburn will watch
thank you thank you